Most modern web applications
have elegant URLs.
This helps people remember links which
then can be easily bookmarked or
shared with others.
As we saw in previous videos, the route
decorator is used to bind a function to
a URL, but there is more to
it than just static paths.
We can make certain paths
of the URL dynamic and
attach multiple rules to a function.
To add variables to a URL, I can specify
a rule with type: variable_name,
where type can be an integer,
string, or another path.
I will make a new route for
my menu app as so, and
use the restaurant id to specify
which menu I want to see.
Note that it's handy to leave
in this trailing slash, and
Flask will render the page,
even when it's not there in the URL.
I will now save my changes and
visit localhost port
5000/restaurants/1/menu and
see my first restaurant menu there.
If I change the integer
after restaurants,
I can see other restaurants
in my database as well.